joe biden is not even yet the
president-elect though he certainly
thinks that he is and
already the facade of moderation and
unity in coming together
is going away biden thinks he's got this
election
wrapped up and so in an interview he
laid out his
first hundred day plan which includes
giving amnesty and a pathway to
citizenship
to 11 million illegal aliens
tell me about day one of the white house
and day one through
100 your first 100 days what are you
what are your priorities going to be on
those first days
some of it's going to depend on the kind
of cooperation i can or cannot get
from the united states congress but i am
going to made a commitment
in the first hundred days i will send a
immigration bill
to the united states senate with a
pathway to citizenship
for over 11 million undocumented people
in america
pathway to citizenship for 11 million
illegal aliens
the vast majority of whom are expected
to vote for democrats
if the democrats have the senate they've
also promised to end the filibuster
pack the court and add two new states
ending the republican party
at the national level and they're just
getting started i'm michael knowles this
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from misanthropic
perspective who says the only smooth
transitions
i see are the segways between michael
and his sponsors that is very kind to
you thank you
we're talking about trans america the
transition
team and transing the kids
you know turning the little boys and
making them think that they're little
girls and that is very
awful i agree those those are not smooth
transitions nor should they be
i i do appreciate that that you all have
picked up on
some of the nice transitions that i've
been trying to make to my sponsors
because i think i think it does contrast
very well with those awful
parents who who are trying to trans the
kids and those awful families
but if you have a great family you
should probably protect the photos you
have of your family with legacy box
legacy box is a safe and affordable way
to digitally preserve
all your home movies and photos that are
currently trapped
on dated formats like vhs or film with
everything going on here is a great way
to ensure the focus remains on your
family this holiday season
a lot of us have irreplaceable moments
on tapes and film reels
that we can no longer watch legacy box
can help you discover what's on all
those tapes and films
and then keep the footage organized and
safe for years to come
i'll tell you this this is just a
warning a a dearly beloved and departed
family member
i had all the photos of this family
member
physical photos i lost them i lost them
and it's heartbreaking and it's terrible
and this is before legacy box i did
manage to find a few more
i immediately send them to legacy box
now at the very least i will have those
forever do not
wait head over there right now right now
they're offering 60
off so that you can have everything
preserved at once for a fraction of the
regular price
once you have these digital versions you
can relax knowing that they'll be secure
for generations
legacy box is something that you can
order in minutes and enjoy
forever do not wait if you wait you
could you could risk losing those
memories forever
this is the best deal of the year go to
legacy box dot com slash knowles
k-w-l-e-s
to take advantage of this limited time
offer get 60 off
this exclusive offer won't last long so
order their kit now send it in whenever
you're ready
it's a sale to remember tremendous
tremendous service legacy box.com
knowles save 60 while supplies last
that's joe biden telling you his first
hundred days he's talking to nbc's
lester holt
if you are watching that clip you'll see
that they're sitting very very far apart
ridiculously far apart
because they're performing the
coronavirus liturgy
the lockdown liturgy of liberalism where
you wear the cloth mask and that's going
to protect you from the virus despite
studies that say that it won't
where you wear the mask when you walk to
your table in a restaurant but then when
you sit down at the table you're in the
magic orb
of health and sanitation so you can take
the mask off
it's all just a silly religious ritual
uh for the false religion of liberalism
so sitting far away i actually think
there's some significance here
the significance of sitting very far
away is the intimacy
that we have had with the donald trump
is uh will not continue if joe biden
is elected president whatever you think
about trump we have seen that guy
up close and personal he tweets all the
time there are misspellings
he gets right in your face he gets right
in the reporter's face he speaks off the
cuff
probably the most transparent president
certainly of my lifetime and
probably in recent history as well that
closeness is not going to
occur if joe biden is the president
you're going to see a distance
from him he's going to repeat the same
platitudes
that we've heard from empty suit
politicians for a long time
he's going to contradict himself it
won't matter he will not be the one
calling the shots or running the show he
will be empowering the
liberal state the same cast of
characters that have been around forever
we talked about yesterday how he's named
john kerry his climate czar
a new position i guess john kerry has
been around since the 70s he's just he's
comes in and out he's a senator he's a
secretary of state doesn't matter how
much he fails he just
remains there a lot of obama alumni
believe that if joe biden is named
president
they will go back to the white house
that is what
you're going to see if if he makes it
there the argument for this by the way
it's not i'm not reading the tea leaves
or something
the left is telling us this themselves
andrea mitchell
on nbc news came out and said of joe
biden's cabinet picks that the best
thing about the cabinet picks
is that they're not political they
are now being told that it is not going
to be political and joe biden is saying
these are people this is a team who is
going to tell me this team will tell me
what i need to know what not what i want
to know that is a big change
that's a big change they're going to
push back on me
first of all andrew mitchell is
contrasting this to the trump white
house where there were vying factions
from the very beginning talk about
pushback
in the biden white house what are they
even pushing back on joe biden doesn't
believe anything
of course they'll just tell him they
won't tell him what he wants to hear
they'll tell him what they want to hear
and he'll just acquiesce because he's an
empty suit
but beyond that i i almost can't believe
she said it with a straight face
until i remember the left's ideology but
she actually said
that the political appointees who are
going to be running the
executive agencies of our government are
not
political what does that mean
okay how can you be a cabinet secretary
and not political
well the reason that andrea mitchell can
say that
is because for the left they believe
that their politics are not really
is not really politics they believe that
their politics is scientific
and the left has said this for 150 years
at least
that they have discovered the science of
history and the science of politics
and they have their expertise and so
they're not having the push and pull
typical political debates that we've had
in republics going back to ancient
greece
no they have discovered the science of
politics and so if you disagree with
them
you've got to be profoundly stupid or
evil or both
in any case it's not legitimate to
disagree
stop making this so political it's this
we've mentioned this on the show before
in this world of leftist political
science
everything becomes political except for
politics which is depoliticized
and handed to experts so i bet she
really does believe this
that the cabinet won't be political
it'll just be scientific it'll just be
common sense
and you better not disagree with it
that's pretty scary because it's so
tone deaf you know one one thing that
i've noticed in the culture and you see
this borne out by various
studies that show that conservatives are
much more willing to hear out liberals
than liberals are willing to hear out
conservatives and the
bombed out cities around this country
from the blm riots probably show you
that
it's that we understand basically what
the left's point
is maybe we we need to be filled in on
the details but we broadly understand
what they believe
they have no idea what we believe they
have no idea that we reject
the the fundamental premises of their
world
view and every time they do kind of
gather that idea they try to shut us up
and ostracize us and call us nazis and
all that sort of thing we're going to
get a whole lot more of that if joe
biden becomes president
on msnbc the anchors couldn't contain
their excitement they described
the cabinet as the avengers to talk
about joe biden's empathy in humanity to
talk about diplomacy being back
it is all an implicit rebuke
of donald trump's foreign policy
stewardship over the last four
years that's right and then just saying
that they're going to do their jobs
and be good stewards of america's role
in
this world and focus on american
diplomacy that in and of itself
um being a rebuke of president trump is
uh
underscores what we've all been living
through in the last four years this is a
president who wanted to be more
isolationist
who wanted to pull back hold on hold on
a second i just need to
before i get into the stupid points
they're trying to make about biden i
need to point out
donald trump has had the most successful
foreign policy of any president since
the end of the cold war
it's not even close he's an isolationist
he's pulling back he's abandoning our
allies
we have had greater peace under donald
trump than under any president
in my lifetime he is pulling away
uh no he's not he's actually solving the
middle east peace crisis
clinton couldn't do it bush couldn't do
it obama couldn't do it
but trump somehow is getting major peace
deals signed with israel and all of
these different arab neighbors
is it just a fluke no he took a
different approach
an approach that was explicitly rejected
by former secretary of state
future climate czar john kerry who said
it could never work
trump tried it it did work peace deals
in serbia
new trade deals with china new trade
deals with mexico new trade deals with
canada
getting the nato allies to start paying
for nato
this had been official u.s policy for
years no president figured out how to do
it trump did
the idea that trump is some isolationist
who bungled foreign policy is insane
he did better at foreign policy and
hopefully he continues to do better at
foreign policy
than any president in the last quarter
century
but then they go on to make their point
about the cabinet and this
is what is so preposterous
they believe that the cabinet this lame
drawling
drooling old desiccated cabinet
or superheroes what we saw today i was
sitting in that room in wilmington um i
was thinking about the fact that joe
biden in some ways
first supporters is fulfilling the
promises that he made on the campaign
charlie said he wanted to have a cabinet
that looked like america and there were
people there on that stage of course
talking about all of their different
accolades and their experience but they
were also talking about their families
who survived the holocaust who survived
coming from cuba and flink
communists who talked about um having
gumbo
diplomacy cooking food cooking southern
food as as the united nations ambassador
of things
um all of those things are what america
is about it's
the other thing i'll just say is i was
talking to a democrat who just said this
also felt like the avengers it felt like
we're being rescued from this this
craziness that we've all lived through
from the last four years and now
here are the superheroes to come and
save us all
here are the superheroes and what are
their qualifications what are their
superpowers
can they fly no can they think
not really but they can look a certain
way
yes they can have different colors of
skin
and this is an amazing superpower
different sexual appendages
i know that you know all those things
were true under trump too but
you know it's super duper under joe
biden
this is identity politics on steroids
right this is what this woman says
we need a cabinet that looks like
america well what do you mean by looks
like america you mean
do you mean in the sense that the
cabinet thinks like americans think
that the cabinet has the same love of
country that
americans generally have that they have
the same interests the same hobbies the
same cares and concerns no
what she means is they've got to be
diverse meaning you know different
colors and sex and everything
and when they say look like america by
the way what they're really saying is
actually look
more diverse than america you have to
have one of
every single type of person with certain
physical traits
there's something beyond stupid here
obviously it's very stupid and shallow
and pretty offensive but there's
something beyond that that's that's even
it's even more depressing which is that
the focus on identity politics here the
color and sex of these cabinet
pics shows you that the individual
members
don't matter at all it doesn't matter if
any of these people
are talented and from the pics that
we've heard of so far they're not
talented
they're not particularly intelligent
they're not particularly accomplished
none of these guys most especially john
kerry
they're just there to fill a space
to be an empty suit because
they are the conduit for the liberal
technocracy to rule
that's the i mean that's the the really
revealing aspect of the identity
politics
is no one is focusing on whether these
people are competent to do their jobs
and
they're not actually but it doesn't
matter because they're not even doing
the jobs
we have had in this country for decades
now
a bureaucracy that operates largely
without democratic oversight
that just makes all our policy for us
the presidents may change but the
foreign policy is supposed to
stay the same the administrations may
come and go
but the giant bureaucracy that employs
millions of people will keep
will keep operating and trump disrupted
that in a limited way
he wasn't able to totally upend the deep
state or the bureaucracy but he made
changes here and there changed policy a
little bit and then the
establishment fought back they think
that they vanquished him we still don't
know for sure
and now they want to govern again
without any of that democratic oversight
and so all of these
these uh cabinet picks and
joe biden himself there will be little
ornaments on the christmas tree little
shiny things to look at
but the substance of the government will
be that
bureaucracy and that makes me feel a
little bit
worried about our future and when i'm
feeling worried about the future i am so
pleased
that i have ready-wise now is a better
time than ever to be prepared with
long-term
nutritional food options ready-wise has
a ton of options such as
emergency meals freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition
new adventure meals for hiking camping
and other outdoor activities
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable
as conservatives it's good to just be
ready
okay i'm not saying you need to have the
apocalypse happen tomorrow
you will just have peace of mind you'll
be a responsible person if you
are ready in the event of some big issue
which
seem to crop up all the time now order
online have nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep
when government resources are strained
it can be days if not weeks before fresh
food is available
do not put yourself in a situation where
you need
food during an emergency be prepared
today i love it makes me sleep easy
this week my listeners can get free
shipping at readywise.com
when entering knowles kendra wles at
checkout or by calling
day 855-453-2945 questions asked return
policy there is no risk taking the
initiative
to get yourself and your family prepared
today that is readywise
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com promo code knowles k-w-l-e-s to
get free
shipping these are the avengers
people do not trust these experts we
have a new poll out that shows people do
not trust
the experts do you know what percentage
of americans
are going to take the wonderful new
vaccine for coronavirus that we were
promised it's going to be 90
effective it's about to come out even
after what nine months of lockdown at
this point
just 51 of americans plan on taking that
vaccine
i don't blame them i don't blame the 49
who don't plan to take that vaccine
right away
why should they trust the vaccine why
should they trust the experts
the same experts who told us you have to
wear the mask or i'm sorry first they
said you can't wear the mask don't wear
the mask it's bad to wear the mask then
they say you have to wear the mask the
mask protects you
now we're getting studies to show the
mask doesn't do very much at all the
ones who said it's going to be 2 million
deaths then they said it's going to be
this then they said it's going to be
that
every single step of the way these idiot
experts have gotten this thing wrong
and now 49 of americans are going to be
castigated as
anti-vaxxers or anti-science or
you know endangering public health
they're probably going to try to find a
way to make the vaccine mandatory
if not from the government level then
from the commerce level you won't be
able to do commerce you won't be able to
get on an airplane perhaps
they're probably going to do that and
49 of americans half the country
is going to say i don't know guys i want
to wait this one out a little bit i
want to make sure you get this one right
i get i'm not i'm not saying
the vaccine is not going to be good i'm
not saying that the vaccine isn't going
to be perfectly safe
what i'm saying is the experts who are
behind this public health dictatorship
have no credibility which is why it is
just a matter of description
that half the country doesn't trust them
and wants to hold off for a little bit
and wants to wait it is not the 49
fault that they don't want to take that
vaccine
it is not half the country's fault it is
the fault of the public health
egghead lab coat wearing tyrannical
idiots
who have zero credibility left and it is
the fault of the media
who have lied and it's the fault of the
politicians through whose empty suits
those experts speak
the media here have
no credibility either and they've pushed
a lot of this
i was watching an interview between
stephen colbert
and barack obama it just shows you if
joe biden ascends to the presidency
what we are going to be in for watching
the news over the next four years or
however long biden would be in office
president obama thank you so much uh for
joining me today it is wonderful to be
here thank you for having me yeah it's
good to see you
i it is good it is good to be seen i've
been seeing you on television but it's
good to see you in person
that's nice and um that's kind of a demo
in some how old are you
are you are you here are you 18 and 54.
i'm not the demographic you're looking
for sorry it's too late i apologize
it doesn't count michelle says hey oh
good yeah good
you know you know she loves you well
i've i've really enjoyed spending some
time with her over the last four years i
know
yeah and and she she's she she adores
you she thinks the world of you
i think you're okay can we just just
take a moment can i just
i don't and i want to talk i just i just
want to take a moment to to
to drink you in for just a moment
because
i'm having to get used to looking at a
president
[Laughter]
again you know i've gotten out of i've
gotten out of the habit
you got i got to warm up for joe biden i
don't want to pull anything when i see
him take the oath of office
you got to ease me into this a little
bit i have
never heard a more flirtatious
conversation than this bizarre
little intimate pow-wow between stephen
colbert and barack obama i feel
like a voyeur watching this this
conversation
i feel like i'm peeking in on two high
school teenagers
you know about to play spin the bottle
or something this is so
revolting how much colbert and the media
fawn over barack obama and i it it's
giving me
flashbacks to 2008 to 2016 when
when chris matthews was getting a thrill
up his leg
seeing barack obama when the the
question there's one question from
a white house reporter they were doing a
really in-depth hard interview and
they said uh mr president mr president
obama
what has enchanted you about the white
house what is
what has enchanted you about this job
wow hard hitting stuff guys
you can't trust the media obviously and
now we're seeing a report out from the
media research center
that the media's suppression
of negative stories about joe biden may
have given him the election if indeed he
won the election
this new poll conducted by mrc shows
that
17 of joe biden's voters said they would
not have voted for him
had they been aware of at least one of
the stories about him either the terror
read accusation
about sexual misconduct or the the
bigger story
which is the corruption involving hunter
biden and ukraine
and china and joe biden getting a
prosecutor fired
and the the biden family enriching
themselves on joe's
half century of public service
that is a very
worrisome thing because the media still
have this
absolute lock over the control of
information we thought that
because of the social media and the new
media we had been able to crack that up
but then big tech three companies in
silicon valley
decided to to come in and weigh in all
of them uniformly on the side
of democrats and totally uh control that
information
i i don't want to be too pessimistic
here
if biden's elected and especially if
they take the senate
you get amnesty for 11 million illegal
aliens very
depending on where what states they're
in very difficult for us to win another
national presidential election if they
in the filibuster they will pack the
court difficult for us to get a good
judicial ruling
if they add two new states to the
country or even one new state
basically impossible for us to win the
presidency again
and impossible for us to investigate big
tech
impossible for us to break up the
establishment media cartel the grip of
the establishment at that point
will at least in the near future be
basically
insurmountable there is a lot at stake
here there i know there are some
republicans who just want to roll over
who just want to say okay well whatever
let's concede this one
don't concede don't concede you have to
exhaust every
single option available to you there's
there is
uh security of the party is on the line
and you know by the way your home
security is on the line it is doorbell
season
the busiest time of the year at your
front door and that is certainly true
at my own house uh right now there's so
much going on
you get a ton of packages you get a ton
of delivery guys you get a ton
of relatives visiting you maybe you want
to see them maybe probably you don't
ring has everything you need to keep an
eye on your home this holiday season and
throughout the year
see and speak to whoever is at your door
from anywhere with video doorbells keep
an eye
on every corner of your house with easy
to install indoor
and outdoor cameras help protect your
whole home with ring alarm a powerful
affordable whole home security system
that you can easily install
yourself i've been giving ring to my
friends as housewarming gifts for years
now i'm the guy who's got a house
because i moved out of crazy la la land
where nobody can afford even a little
tiny hovel you know in
a little shanty town uh now i'm in a
good tennessee breathing the sweet air
of freedom so i'll be able to have a
house
and i'm so excited to get my ring set up
for a limited time go to ring.com
knowles k-w-l-e-s to receive special
black friday and cyber monday offers
that is ring dot com slash knowles w
l e s
so the democrats could have a lock
on the government more so than they
already do and
despite the virus and the lockdown and
all the economic problems that
they largely caused there's this
there's a simple answer according to the
democrats which is how are you going to
deal with the pandemic how are you going
to reopen the economy
aoc is the answer pay people to stay at
home
she uh tweeted out to get the virus
under control we need to pay
people to stay home now there's a
there's a first order problem with this
and then there's a deeper problem with
this the first order one
is the kind of typical conservative
rejoinder to these ideas which is oh
yeah being paid to stay home sounds
great
but who's going to pay for it you know
he'll often say yeah free health care
sounds great but who's going to pay for
it you know
sure that's a problem actually i don't
know that
i i understand why that's a clever
answer
and that we do have to deal with the
accounting problem here
but we should go a step further and
realize it's actually a bad
thing to be paid to stay home we don't
want that it doesn't sound good
it's actually a bad thing to get lots of
stuff
for free and to have the government
control your health care
to have the government control these
decisions of life and death for you it's
bad
it's not even good in theory even if we
didn't have to pay for it
because it misunderstands human nature
the human role in the world and the
dignity of work
work confers dignity
diligence is a virtue that is according
to the old standard which we all
believed until like five seconds ago now
according to the new standard of wokism
or call it political correctness or
quote just leftism generally
work does not confer any dignity work is
just a burden it's dishonorable
it's shameful it's oppressive it's
unfair we shouldn't have to do it it's
based on
historical or even if you're not
oppressed you're historically your
ancestors are oppressed so you
it's it's a shame for you to have to
work and diligence is not a virtue sloth
is then
becomes a virtue diligence is just oh
you're
you're either a fool for for running
you're
running the wheels on this unjust
illegitimate system
or you're just uh
just wasting your time that could be so
much better spent
writing poetry or being a photographer
nancy pelosi said this when they passed
obamacare she said this is an
entrepreneurial bill
because no longer will people be stuck
in jobs no they won't be stuck in jobs
to get healthcare now they can go
and be a photographer or an artist
got news for you most people are not
good artists
we don't need we don't have a a dearth
of artists in this country
okay and art has never been particularly
profitable for people usu for
most of human history it's a something
you do out of love and you have the idea
of the starving artist
you have to work for these things that
is good and the
the right i think still understands this
the left does not
the problem is spend spend spend is the
republican answer to all these things
too
you know it's why the debt keeps growing
it's actually why the
the left-wing establishment has
tolerated certain republican
administrations
because it doesn't threaten their
government expansion
you know republicans might cut taxes but
they'll just borrow more money so
the spend spent spend continues to go on
now amid all of this sadness and chaos
and degradation of our white house and
our country
we did continue at least one tradition
yesterday this was
one wonderful tradition president trump
one of the most peace-loving presidents
in the last hundred years
decided to have mercy again
and he pardoned one of the thanksgiving
turkeys take a listen
and now it's time for the moment of our
guest of honor
they've been waiting and in this case
he's been waiting for this
and uh bring him out look at that
beautiful beautiful bird
oh so lucky that is a lucky bird corn
i hereby grant you a full pardon
thank you porn
[Applause]
happy thanksgiving to everybody thank
you very much
joe biden is talking about unity and
coming together and how we have to get
back to normal
of course he doesn't really mean any of
that he his partisans are talking about
enemy lists and aoc is talking about it
jay tapper's talking about the trump
accountability project he's installing
these radical people who are going to do
radical things and the government take
away
our constitutional rights to
self-governance so he doesn't mean any
of that do you know what does bring us
together though the turkey pardon
this is a great tradition we need more
of these in america
the turkey pardon is so ridiculous it's
bizarre it's been going on for what 60
70 years now
there's no point to it it's pretty weird
good
we need more of those things the right
understands the importance of tradition
of ritual
of things we all do together and maybe
we can't rationally explain why we do
them and maybe they don't seem to serve
a
utilitarian purpose but they're good
they have they give us some culture
they bring us together in a national
purpose even if it's
pardoning a turkey and sending him to a
farm in upstate new york
the left does not get that and some
people on the right
like in particular libertarians are a
little guilty of this
don't get this either they want
everything in their government to be
rational
they want it all to have make perfect
utilitarian sense
and make perfect economic sense there's
nothing
economically beneficial about pardoning
a turkey but it is
cultural it is something that we can't
quite
uh calculate the effect of but it is a a
nice moment when we can all just sort of
laugh
and let loose a little bit and feel a
little more relaxed and calm with one
another
that's an important thing it's why we
extol the virtues of traditions
and why we hate that kind of crazy
rationalist left-wing
calculation there's one meme i have to
get to before we get to the mailbag
this meme came up earlier this week it
went viral on
the internet it's from women on top
and it had two pictures it says my mom
at age 31
and me at age 31 and my mom at age 31
she's standing there she looks like
she's
in the 80s or something and she's got
these two kids and she's smiling and
she's hugging her kids
then me at age 31 it's a gal wearing
tights
with a roller bag and a
probably expensive purse here a chanel
purse and then a glass of champagne
okay and so you read then you say oh
gosh okay is this saying that this poor
woman is just not living as fulfilling a
life as her mother did that's kind of
sad
but then there was a another image that
went with it
this is a picture of a woman and a guy
and a kid
obviously they're married they have this
kid it says an established and complete
woman with her family
and then there's a picture of a woman
wearing a sort of low-cut
top eating pizza sitting on a table with
also with a glass of champagne this
woman really likes champagne i don't
know i don't know why all times of day
walking through the airport this lady
needs to booze up who knows why
and it says also an established and
complete
woman now i realize the point of this
they're saying look
any of your choices are not only fine
and acceptable
but they are equally conducive to human
flourishing there's nothing
intrinsically good about having kids or
settling down or getting married or
having a family
that is exactly as
good and purposeful and productive
as sitting and drinking champagne and
cold pizza
or or drinking champagne with expensive
luggage walking through an airport
not everybody gets to be to get married
not everybody it is a privilege it's a
nice thing some people are called to
other
other things some people are called a
celibacy some people are called to
religious life
some people are called to be married not
everyone gets to have a kid
some people suffer from infertility some
people maybe you can adopt a kid
but not everyone gets that kids are a
blessing right
however it is good to be married
it is better to be married and settle
down than it
is to just pursue your own appetites and
drink champagne all day long
all the way through your whole life it
is good
to have kids some people don't get to
have kids
we all suffer but it is good it is
better to have kids
than to choose not to have kids because
you want to pursue your own appetites
and just do whatever you want all the
time
someone tweeted this out the other day
they said why do people want to get
married and have kids when you could
do drugs in foreign countries i assume
a comedian but i think there was a lot
of
earnestness in what she was saying for
for a lot of millennials
we need to have a standard and i think
conservatives need to
stop this kind of nonsense there are a
lot of conservatives who would say that
yeah just do whatever you want
do whatever you want you do you i who am
i to judge i can't
no that that's a dereliction of duty in
a dereliction of leadership and it's
making people miserable
and the reason by the way that these
these images work
is because it says me at age 31 and
when you're in your 30s you're still
like having fun and you're young and you
can do whatever you want
but these things have effects later on
in life and if you're
still boozing and just waking up with
bottles of champagne at age 61
maybe something's gone a little wrong
your partying days should be over at
that point
you should settle yourself a little bit
more and train your habits
and it's it's not not quite as glamorous
at that point
and this is lying to women in particular
and women have become
more miserable both in relative to men
and in absolute terms as measured by
any social scientific survey since the
1970s
take social science with a grain of salt
but but all of them show it
and why is that it's because of these
sorts of lies of feminism and
conservatives i think have abandoned
them too
and conservatives because we just think
it's easier to throw up our hands and
say well who am i to judge i don't you
know whatever that's fine you do you
no it's not true that kind of attitude
toward life will
make you miserable never too late to
throw that attitude out but you
absolutely
should let's get to the mailbag because
thanksgiving is almost here that means
black friday is almost here too
since last year's black friday deal we
have been consistently adding more
features and products
to our membership program we're really
excited about it to name a few things we
have added more exclusive readers past
content
our insider and above members can now
stream our content on apple tv and roku
which is very exciting
because of all the new content we're
adding such as a fifth day to the
michael knowles show
starting friday december 4th we're gonna
be five days a week and we're going to
radio too
you also get not one but two leftist
years tumblers early access to our daily
wire merch and daily discussions with
our writers and special guests
we're also continuing to add new
features and products like the entire
prageru library
which is currently being added to the
website which is very good because i
have a show at prageru called the book
club
we're adding content from candace owens
who will be launching a new show with us
early next year
needless to say we're pretty excited
about this year's deal and you will not
want to miss it head on over to
dailywire.com we'll be right back with
the mailbag
all right first question from wolfgang
dear austere author of mostly written
books
i joined all access in may and want to
extend my thanks to each of you for your
daily bits of faithful wisdom thank you
very much
i've been told that thursday is about
commemorating racism and destruction
but i will be celebrating in the usual
way by giving thanks for the people and
circumstances
god has set around me and the folks at
daily wire will be on that list of
gratitude how will you be celebrating
happy thanksgiving to you and yours
oh that's so kind you know this year uh
we're we're not
unfortunately not going to be able to
travel to see our family for
thanksgiving
um part of that is the covid
restrictions and we just moved to
nashville so i
actually will be celebrating with the
daily wire as well we're going to go
over
and hang with some of the guys at daily
wire and have a nice thanksgiving it'll
be
lovely i'm glad you brought this up
because this this is a point it actually
ties right in with the the point about
tradition
that we were just discussing
this is the 400th anniversary of the
landing of the mayflower
1620 is when the mayflower lands the
plymouth the
the pilgrims rather get off at plymouth
rock through a very complex and very
interesting
history and providential history they
encounter these
indians who become the wampanoag nation
the providence of it is unbelievable
these pilgrims land 300 miles
off course at the wrong time they land
on the beach
and they hear an indian come out and
speak to them in english
greetings englishmen that was
samuset an indian who spoke broken
english
and then after that came squanto perhaps
the only indian in the new world
in the entire hemisphere who was fluent
in english
because he had been kidnapped earlier
brought back to europe lived in
in spain was rescued probably by monks
sent to london lived in london talked to
the pilgrims about england which they
all knew about
and then hopped a ship somehow got back
he lands in the new world he finds out
that his tribe is dead
because they have been wiped out by
disease makes it all the way down is
taken as a prisoner
of massasoit who is the chief of what
became the wampanoag nation
and then that just just so happens to be
there
right where and when the pilgrims land
you couldn't
if you don't believe in providence after
hearing that history i don't i don't
know what would make you so
and then the the pilgrims you know form
a
really important alliance with massasoit
messes so it allies with the pilgrims he
grows his power
they take out worse indians who are
trying to attack the englishman
then peace persists for a couple of
decades and then unfortunately
one of massasoit's sons who took an
english name philip
decided based on faulty intelligence
that the pilgrims had turned on him
historical records just probably was not
the case
and this led to a bloody war some of the
indians still sided with the pilgrims
but then
and peace ends in the region just it's
an incredibly complex
history and the the shallow and
ridiculous idea
that that the pilgrims came and the
englishman just slaughtered all those
helpless poor innocent naive indians
is so offensive to the indians because
it doesn't treat them like human beings
treats them like innocent little
children you know who don't know any
better no these were real men they knew
what they were doing
these were diplomats these were
statesmen these were fighters these were
warriors
and we had alliances and we had battles
and those sorts of things
uh all of that to say the 1619 project
is a year year earlier right and it
doesn't want to frame our country
in 1620 when the pilgrims land it wants
to frame our country in 1619
in virginia when a slave ship landed the
new york times is clear about this
nicole hannah jones the anti-historical
journalist who who put out the project
said
this is not even so much about rewriting
history as it is
although she did rewrite history and
then had to correct it even though she
got the pulitzer prize
but it's not so much about rewriting
history it's about reframing american
history
what that means is you know we can draw
our national identity in mythos
from anything you could draw it from
world war ii and we do in some part
you could draw it from the civil war you
could draw it from the revolutionary war
you could draw it from the era of good
feelings you could draw it from the
french indian war which actually maybe
we should
you could draw it from jamestown you
could draw it from plymouth you could
draw it from that ship in virginia
the way you frame it is not about facts
it's about feelings actually it's about
how you feel toward your country do you
love your country do you hate your
country
if you love your country then you'll
take these people seriously and be
grateful for the country they gave you
and give thanks
if you hate your country then you will
you will attack it you'll attack all of
these man you'll say it's hopelessly
bigoted and you'll only talk about all
the terrible things that ever happened
which will by the way always happen
everywhere in the world because this is
a fallen broken world
it is a choice as to whether or not you
want to love your country or not
it is your duty it is your duty to love
your country
patriotism is an extension of your
affilial piety of your love of your
parents
and it's deeply immoral and
disrespectful for you to hate your own
country that's what the left is doing
right now you should not do that you
should break bread and give thanks
for not just all the blessings we have
right now but all the guys in 1620 who
gave it to us
from andrew hello michael you said that
the way rudy giuliani laughed at the cnn
journalist was actually a good thing
wouldn't you think that this is a bad
road to go down for conservatives to be
okay with laughing at people because of
who they work for
when they literally did nothing wrong it
reminded me of richard dawkins saying to
go out and mock religious people
just because they believe in god how is
the right being okay with this
just just from being from cnn not as bad
as
what richard dawkins said just from
believing in god thanks
love your show and all that you do yeah
there's a difference here namely it is
good to believe in god it is bad to work
for cnn
that's it first of all i'm not convinced
this reporter did nothing wrong i mean
this reporter
was asking dishonest questions and cnn
is is a fake news
uh outlet not meaning that they never
get anything right but just meaning that
they're not the news they're an activist
organization for
the democrats and they pretend to be a
news organization
but i'd actually like to push beyond
that
what we have been stuck in on the right
is this kind of
limp proceduralism for a long time
where we only talk about the form of
politics
we don't talk about the substance of
politics so a good example of this would
be that weird drag queen liturgy that we
saw the other day where they tried to
trans the kids
the the the conservative quote-unquote
who only cares about the form of things
we'll say oh there's
we should not prosecute the adults who
are transiting the kids
and encouraging the kid little boys to
call themselves little girls we
shouldn't prosecute them
because look that's their belief they
believe that you should trans the kids
and i believe that you shouldn't trans
the kids
and who's to say which one's right so
they can do them
and we can do us and you can't legislate
morality
even though you necessarily always
legislate morality because that's what
laws are
they all refer to the moral order you
say you can't do that so we can't make a
distinction between the two things
so let's just let them both exist no
no the left doesn't do this and
conservatives didn't do this until like
15 years ago
it is it is good to believe in god and
god exists
so people should not be mocked for
believing in god because that's the
correct opinion
if anything people should be mocked for
not believing in god or at the very
least they should be persuaded that
they're
wrong people should be mocked for
working for cnn or for taking cnn
seriously because it is a hack
dishonest fraudulent news channel
we can know these things because we can
ascertain truth
maybe not perfectly all of the time but
we do have faculties of reason which are
not
infinite but they're pretty good and we
can do that we're stuck in such a
radical subjectivism right now
that we know we lack the confidence to
make any truth claims about the world
it's why or just you can see it in our
language people
once stated facts they say this is a
leftist year's tumblr
then they would say i think this is a
leftist year's tumblr then they would
say
i feel like this is a leftist ears
tumbler and then they added like like
like
to everything they're saying what does
that mean well you go from
a statement of fact which can be refuted
and which implies that you're going to
you're going to force your views on
somebody and you say i think
a little more distance then you say i
believe a little more distance then you
say i feel
well you can't argue with a feeling
right a feeling is just a sort of sense
or a taste or a preference
then when you add like it creates a
simile out of every every sentence you
say
it creates a distance so you're never
saying a statement of fact
this is a tumblr you're saying this is
like a tumblr
okay i guess it could be like a tumblr
in some way but what i want to say is
the thing itself have confidence use
your brain
don't be afraid to state the truth these
are long answers today but they're
very good questions from justin michael
how could trump possibly have
underperformed with white males that
makes absolutely no sense to me help
yeah i don't really believe it i don't i
don't these machine cities
we know probably gave us quite a lot of
fraud and the evidence i'm using to back
this up is
they stopped counting they stopped to
the count on election night
and then they started up and then they
said they weren't going to start up
until the next day but actually in
certain places like in georgia they they
illegally started up in the middle of
the night without any poll watchers they
turned poll watchers away so
i don't really necessarily believe that
trump lost
among white guys i suppose it's possible
and part of the reason for that is that
trump doesn't do well among
people who have been brainwashed in
college and white guys do go to college
at a pretty high rate so
it's possible i guess but you know i
don't know i'd like to let the legal
process play out to see what
what happened during this uh during this
entire election
last question michael hello michael on
today's episode you touched briefly on
the list of catholic leaders who have
defended the death penalty though you
did not
delve into their arguments as a catholic
i'm very interested to hear you go
through
a few of the most compelling theological
and philosophical arguments in favor of
capital punishment
from a catholic perspective you know
there's a really good book on this
i think who wrote it was it ed phaser
who wrote that book
i think it was i think ed phaser wrote
that boy i forget the name of it escapes
me now by
his blood shall be shed or something to
that effect but uh there's a good essay
by my friend and priest father george
rutler called
hanging concentrates the mind i really
like this because
we always talk about the um
the three types of justice right there
is
rehabilitative there's a rehabilitative
purpose of criminal justice right to
make the criminal better
then there's the deterrent effect which
is to stop people from committing the
same crime
and then there's the retributive effect
which is you just
you justice demands that we punish
people for committing crimes even if it
doesn't rehabilitate them and even if it
doesn't deter the crime just
justice demands it that you have to be
punished
so with capital punishment people think
it's purely
retributive but it actually does have a
deterrent effect part of the reason it
does not appear to right now is because
someone gets capital punishment they
don't actually get zapped for 30 years
so there's such a long lag and a lot of
people just die on death row
but what my my friend father rutler
points out is there is a rehabilitative
effect too and it comes from a line from
dr johnson which is depend upon it sir
when a man knows he's to be hanged in a
fortnight
it concentrates his mind wonderfully the
idea that when you are confronted with
death
you will get your priorities in order
there's this idea that you can let
someone languish on death row for 30
years and maybe they'll have a
conversion
and you know come to christ and get
their life in order but
you can also have that experience on the
scaffold and i think actually maybe
you're more likely to when you
when you're faced with the reality of
your mortality and of your immorality
so that's one argument that from a just
a scriptural argument is
saint paul explicitly defends capital
punishment as does
thomas aquinas write saint paul says
that uh the state does not wield the
sword in vain
and that the the civil authority is
acting
as a mediator of justice when it doles
out capital punishment
uh thomas aquinas talks about this
thomas aquinas i believe defends capital
punishment for heretics too by the way
so pretty uh to use the the popular word
pretty based you know it's pretty
pretty hardcore pretty pretty
conservative um
and just the argument for that is that
the state has a role in justice
you know and that's that's just a fact
and it's not just a little bit of
justice and uh
state just it's not that the state can
mediate justice
but only up to five years in prison no
the state has a role in justice
including all of the potential
consequences of someone committing a
crime this has been the case for
all of the history of the catholic
church and now some people want to
pretend that is not the case but
unfortunately for them it is okay that's
our show
let's give thanks let's concentrate our
mind hopefully not on the scaffold
hopefully
in front of thanksgiving turkey i'm very
thankful for all of you thank you for
tuning in as always
i will see you next week
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more
see you there